we just got samsung's brand new s22
ultra in the office and there's no doubt
a ton of hype over this phone for good
reason but what we're gonna find out in
this video is if it can take down the
iphone 13 pro max yes that's apple's
flagship and to do that we're going to
be testing everything including the
display quality the performance speaker
quality the physical dimensions and
design the thermals display dimming and
everything else including the cameras as
well so let's jump right into it all
right now taking the cover off and look
at that there's the new s22 wow this
looks so much like the old note in fact
i have the note 20 ultra right here
and putting them side by side this is
hilarious
it's almost identical
so basically the s22 ultra is literally
a note 20 ultra with updated internals
is what it looks like and i do want to
mention that we're going to be doing a
full comparison between the note 22
ultra and the s22 ultra so if you're not
already subscribed go ahead and do that
right now so you don't miss out now what
i'm really curious about is the design
of the back and how it looks in real
life
wow look at that
this um yeah this thing is beautiful wow
look at that just separated camera bumps
just how i like it let's take this off
wow that's really good i don't know guys
the old s21 ultra the design of the
camera bumps was horrible it's ugly look
at this thing it's just a chunk it's a
brick attached to the side that blends
into the frame i literally guys i
couldn't stand this design but this new
one
this looks so incredibly clean comparing
it to the iphone 13 pro max
man it's right up there it looks so good
now i do want to mention i have a
leather skin from nomad on my iphone but
behind that is the matte glass texture
and this like feels
just as good like wow
i'm shocked at how good this looks and
now holding both of these in my hands
even though the s22 ultra seems bigger
it actually is a little bit more
comfortable because the iphone has those
flat chunky thick sides so it doesn't
really wrap around your palm but this
the smooth sides and the edges really
feels nice and comfortable and it kind
of makes me miss the old iphone 11
design
and you do have the boxy top and bottom
but it doesn't feel like it's really
jamming into my palm too much so
comfort's pretty good and of course we
have the s pen hidden at the bottom this
is actually a really important feature
because last year's s21 ultra supported
the s pen but you had nowhere to put it
so it had to be outside of the phone so
having this note design
is definitely a big win and we'll cover
the s pen in just a minute and if i were
to compare and choose a winner for the
overall design aspects i would honestly
have to give it to the s22 ultra because
of that clean hole punch the thin bezels
that are thinner than the iphone and of
course this new camera bump design with
the white contrast that i really really
like and now with that said let's go
through the setup process and here i'm
going to add a fingerprint using the
really good under display fingerprint
scanner so let's get this set up and
there you go just like that
adding my fingerprint and apparently
this works
better than it has before for years so
there you go the fingerprint is added
and i do want to mention that with the
iphone 13 pro max the really nice new
feature that apple is adding is that
they're making face id finally work with
masks and that is a huge deal because i
personally believe they no longer need
under display touch id if face id works
well so let me pull out a mask i got it
on and watch this
there you go i just unlocked my iphone
with the mask on and now testing out the
fingerprint sensor i cannot believe
how good this is working compared to how
it did with the
older samsung devices like this is
perfect and i'm very impressed yeah
super fast but still i prefer face id
because it's automatic and now before we
get into comparing the displays and all
the differences in quality brightness
and everything else let's go ahead and
test out the speaker quality
[Music]
all right i don't know about you guys
but the iphone completely destroyed the
s22 ultra which is really weird because
it's usually back and forth winner
winner winner but this time the s12
ultra is worse because the iphone has
brighter cleaner sharper highs as well
as louder mids and especially better and
deeper bass it just blows the speakers
away now what makes me think is what if
samsung had to basically put in worse
speakers because it has a larger battery
5 000 milliamp hours compared to 4500 in
the old note 20 ultra design so we're
actually going to find that out by
comparing these speakers to the s21
ultra and the note 20 ultra so
definitely subscribe and now with that
said let's go ahead and compare the
displays now the first thing i notice is
that the bezels on the s22 ultra are
just so much thinner than the ones on
the iphone especially on the sides right
here because of that curved display
compared to the flat design on the
iphone
and the biggest difference is that hole
punch camera which looks so much more
clean compared to the notch even though
the notch is smaller and that top bezel
is also much thinner whereas the bottom
one is around the same but man the
bezels on this thing just looks so good
and so nice and in terms of maximum
brightness samsung actually markets up
to 1750 maximum that's with hdr compared
to 1200 only on the iphone 13 pro max
but now that i've raised it up using the
regular typical brightness they almost
look identical which is weird because it
seems like the samsung should be
brighter and in the past the samsung was
always a little bit dimmer than the
iphone but now it looks like they
finally caught up in terms of just
maxing out the slider yourself without
going outside or without using hdr now
seeing as we actually have to watch some
hdr content to get up to that full 1750
nits i have an hdr youtube video open
right here with the same settings on
both the iphone and the samsung so
there you go alright guys this is really
weird because the iphone even though it
only goes up to 1200 instead of 1750 it
looks generally brighter in almost every
scene oh especially this one inside the
building that is so weird that it looks
brighter it doesn't make any sense now i
did update the youtube app on both
phones and i don't know why the
samsung's not getting that bright now
one thing i'm noticing is that the peak
brightness of like let's say the clouds
and the sun they're actually very
similar but everything else including
the mids the shadows everything else is
just kind of crushed or dimmed down on
the samsung compared to the iphone which
kind of
gets everything brought up and it looks
brighter and i'd say nicer especially in
terms of the colors especially right
here you could look the iphone's
reproducing some really nice red shades
and the green shades and the leaves yep
and right here i am seeing the fireworks
where the bright flashes are a little
bit brighter on the note but everything
else is dimmer so the hdr video just
ended and let me tell you guys i am
disappointed because i thought samsung's
1750 knit rating would just be
mind-blowing compared to the iphone but
it's actually quite the opposite with
the iphone looking better in almost all
of the scenes and i wonder if that's
just the hdr processing that's better on
the iphone maybe in terms of the app
software or something else but the
iphone actually wins here and now let's
finally get into performance testing and
this is a big deal because the s22 ultra
has the brand new snapdragon 8 gen 1
chip which is supposed to be a pretty
big improvement on the graphics side but
let's start with the cpu of course we
have the iphone 13 pro max with the a15
bionic with the performance cores
clocked in at 3.23 gigahertz with six
gigs of ram and then on the other hand
we have 12 gigs of ram so double and we
have a single core that's clocked at 3.0
which is a little bit lower but let's go
ahead and start this benchmark we have
our scores and it looks like both single
core and multi-core is 38
faster on the iphone and let me tell you
guys i've never been this disappointed
because of all of the hype with the
snapdragon 8 gen 1 including the whole
rebranding and the performance is just
so far behind in fact it's so far behind
that
the iphone 11 had faster single core and
almost as much multi-core performance
which is just mind-blowing that they're
that far behind apple and with that said
i know that was just a raw power
benchmark so let's actually run a
speedometer web browsing test to see how
that's going to translate into kind of
real world usage and look at that the
iphone is actually two and a half times
faster in this test so it's basically
gonna make everything more snappy now of
course the samsung has a lot of power
and more than enough than what you would
need but with the iphone if you still
have it three or four or five years down
the road that extra power is gonna make
it work better in the future compared to
this that has less and it might be
struggling with apps later on now while
the cpu performance isn't that
impressive with the snapdragon 8 gen 1
the big improvement is actually the
graphics and the hype was saying that
it's basically competitive with the
iphone so let's go ahead and run
3dmark's wildlife extreme unlimited test
and we're going to be taking a look at
the display dimming to see if it dims
and the thermals and the heat as well so
let's run and it looks like the iphone
was faster it got over 18
higher in terms of the score
and that's actually really interesting
because a lot of the hype and the test
showed that the snapdragon 8 gen 1
basically matched or even sometimes beat
the a15 but here we see that is not the
case at all all right and now i turned
on the extreme stress test and the point
of this is to see if we get any display
dimming on either of these phones and
then we're going to check the
temperatures to see which one gets hot
and which one does not
and so far it does look like
the frames per second is higher visibly
higher on the iphone and it looks much
worse than the 18 difference we saw
earlier and well i think the iphone just
dimmed
i don't know if you guys saw there or
not but it dimmed down slightly as far
as i know
oh there you go
and now the samsung is quite a bit
brighter oh it dimmed again look how
dark that is oh wow man looks like the
iphone is still struggling with
overheating or in terms of the dimming
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna pull
out a thermal camera and take a look and
now i'm looking at the thermals between
both of these and it is saying that the
samsung is
hotter so let's actually zoom in
onto the iphone we're looking at 41
degrees celsius
and then over to the samsung whoa 45
degrees that's actually a huge
huge difference
44
definitely hotter on the samsung and you
can see that the iphone just has one
hotspot
and like the entire samsung
looks pretty hot and the reason for that
is because the samsung has a really good
cooling system where it has the vapor
chamber system that spreads the heat
which is actually very good compared to
the iphone that does not have that
and even still it's only 40 degrees
celsius so man i wish apple gave it a
better cooling system so it didn't dim
and i am noticing that the samsung has
also dimmed down not quite to the same
level as the iphone but it's definitely
dim and in terms of the fps the iphone
is still beating it out in basically
every scene and you know what i think
i'm actually going to be doing a gaming
comparison between the two testing out
the gaming performance in terms of the
fps dimming and everything else so if
you want to see that definitely
subscribe right now now before i get
into other differences like the battery
life and the cameras i do want to talk
about this s pen first of all i'm very
happy that you can put it into the
chassis but let's test it out oh look at
that
has a very interesting
paper like sound effect and as far as i
know it's incredibly responsive so this
is one of the benefits to having the s
pen compared to the iphone that does not
support the apple pencil and that's
because apple wants you to buy an ipad
because even the budget ipad supports
the apple pencil but not the iphone so
if you like to take a lot of handwritten
notes the samsung is definitely the way
to go and now let's talk about the
battery life first of all the battery
size or the milliamp hours on the s22
ultra is about 15 percent larger than on
the iphone but according to mr who's the
boss's battery life test
the iphone actually got 2 hours and 19
minutes more screen on time than the s22
ultra which doesn't really make sense
apart from the software optimizations
and the worst part of all is that the
s22 ultra scored worse than last year's
s21 ultra which doesn't really make
sense but the iphone is still the
battery life king and now getting into
the camera differences i've got to say
that apple has been kind of lagging
behind because samsung now has four
cameras on the back including a 3x
telephoto and a 10x telephoto and we've
been hearing that it's been a really
really good improvement and then on the
front side the s22 ultra has a 40
megapixel selfie camera compared to just
12 on the iphone just like it was before
and as far as the main rear camera the
samsung has a 108 megapixel resolution
camera compared to just 12 on the iphone
so that gives them a sharpness advantage
as well as allowing them to shoot an 8k
video so we're actually very excited to
test this because tomorrow we're gonna
be releasing our blind unbiased camera
comparison which is always very fun all
three of us are looking and examining
the photos so if you're not already
subscribed do so right now so you don't
miss that and now with all that said
let's get into my conclusion over all
the things that we tested now first of
all the price on this thing is expensive
thirteen hundred dollars compared to
eleven hundred so it's two 200 more
expensive
and the thing is quite a few of the
marketable things that samsung mentioned
they're a little bit disappointing
compared to what i was expecting first
of all the speakers are nowhere near
what i was expecting
much worse than the iphone and the
display quality honestly it's not nearly
as bright as i thought it would be so
that's also disappointing now i think
the biggest saving grace is the
beautiful design
i love these camera bumps so that's
definitely a plus but i think it's all
gonna have to come down to the camera
quality because that is very important
to a lot of people so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above so you
don't miss out on our future videos and
definitely check out one right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]